Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Grant from Iowa City. Grant,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. So you might have already
addressed this question in the past at some
point. So I apologize if that's the case, but
apology accepted. Great. But what, if anything,
do you think can be done to regain the majority
of people's confidence in the fairness and
security of the voting and election process? Well.
Speaker 1: The reason I love this question is that
it's based on a false premise, and I understand
why you're asking it this way. Most people do
trust the election results that we've had in
the United States. It's it's not a majority that
doubts the election results, which should make
us ask why do those claims that most people don't
believe get so much attention and amplification?
And it's because there is one side, the Republican
Party, that has abandoned policy and they want
to try to win through hijinx and election
interference and getting votes thrown out or
closing polling places, etc.. Your question more
generically would be what can we do to increase
confidence in our election systems? But you said,
how can we get back to a majority? We have a
majority who already trust our election system.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I think I just I asked a poorly
I guess I was more so wondering,
like the people who don't trust it,
how do we regain the majority of those people?
Speaker 1: Sadly, it's not simple. And here's why.
When critical thinking is is weakened and
diminished in the United States, it creates
a vacuum into which elected officials on any side
could convince their followers of obviously untrue
things. You look at some of the people who say
they're going to vote for Herschel Walker despite
all of the claims against him, and they go now.
Well, he apologized and he's denying it. And it
was something he did when he was young. He was 50
and on and on. They can explain it away, however.
And so when you have such a population that's
vulnerable to non thinking and disinformation,
etc., if the Republican Party decides we benefit
from convincing our followers that the elections
aren't fair, it's very hard to disabuse folks of
that belief. So unfortunately, I hate to be such
a downer on this. We need to basically vaccinate
people against falling for false beliefs like this
in the first place, which goes back to what we
teach starting in middle school and in high school
and getting people not to fall for this stuff in
the first place. So it's a very big uphill battle.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: To the extent one other idea would be.
If Republicans stop believing it's to their
advantage to tell the it was rigged story,
then they would stop doing it. And I just
broke a glass. Wow. That was very loud.
And but but to the extent that they continue to
benefit from that, they're going to keep doing it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's probably very
true. All right, well, let's take my call.
Speaker 1: No problem. I'm actually wondering
how loud that was. We do have broken glass
in the studio, so we're going to have to
we're going to have to deal with that in
a moment. But let's continue with let's
continue with calls for the time being